et autres dossiers judiciaires la
reprise aujourd'hui du procès médiatique
lui aussi des treize accusés dans la
sphère du cyber harcèlement de la jeune
milla les précisions de monein mode et
l'or bonsoir mona vous êtes devant le
tribunal pour l'audience de ces prévenus
qui est toujours en cours
oui exactement stéphanie cette nouvelle
audience allah commencé tôt ce matin
c'est treize prévenus ils ont dû
s'exprimer à la barre ils sont jugés
pour avoir harcelé et menacé de mort est
la jeune milla et qui avait tenu des
propos insultants sur l'islam c'est
devenu une affaire aux dimensions
politiques et judiciaires et aux
conséquences bien réelles pour la jeune
fille qui aujourd'hui vit recluse mais
également pour ceux qui la harcelait en
ligne une affaire qui avait divisé
l'opinion politique je voulais dit elle
est prêt les prévenus étaient été tenus
fait d'exprimer leur geste aujourd'hui
devant milla pourquoi il avait voulu la
mort de cette jeune fille ils ont été
tenus de s'expliquer ils ont témoigné
tour à tour c'était des femmes et des
hommes entre 18 ans et 35 ans tous
viennent de milieux différents la
plupart sont sans aucun antécédent
judiciaire ils viennent de tous milieux
de la france certains sont chrétiens
d'autres ratés certains musulmans
certains ont d'autant plus tenu à
s'excuser publiquement devant milla lors
de cette audience il confesse avoir
réagi à chaud et regrettent leurs tweets
et mona le tour également de la maman de
millas d'être entendu
oui exactement ça a été un moment assez
fort de cette audience
elle a tenu tête malgré lé tentatives de
déstabilisation des voca des avocats
pardon de la défense selon elle sa fille
subit un déferlement de haine quotidien
continue je cite nous avons vécu un
cataclysme
aujourd'hui elle ne peut plus se
projeter dit elle elle estime que les
propos 2000 a envers l islam est bien
n'était qu'une riposte aux insultes
concernant son homosexualité selon la
mère il n'y a jamais eu de récupération
politique est le fil conducteur de tout
cela a été à la critique de l'islam et
bonnart à ce que me l'a elle même s'est
exprimé
oui oui millas est exprimé en fin
d'audience qui est toujours en cours
d'ailleurs elle s'est exprimée à la
barre vêtue d'une robe noire très émue
elle a eu du mal à s'exprimer devant ses
treize prévenus au début elle explique
les menaces de mort c'est permanent je
n'ai jamais un seul moment de
tranquillité
je ne serai jamais habitué à souffrir
voici lé premier mot de la jeune fille
dès qu'elle a commencé à la barre elle
dit je cite
ils sont fiers et d'être tous ensemble
ils sont fiers des méchancetés qu'ils
écrivent en regardant lé 13 harceleur
prévenu ici devant lors de cette
audience le cyberharcèlement elle c'est
destructeur elle dit elle elle dans la
journée l avocat de me la mettre richard
malka s'est exprimé il estime que la
jeune fille a subi un lynchage numérique
et se dit satisfait de pouvoir enfin
entendre les témoignages de ces prévenus
et tout locaux elle et elle est contente
que enfin on aborde le fond de ce procès
allait évidemment contente que le
fondement juridique sur la sur lequel
ces poursuites sont fondées soit validé
très important que ça le soit on lui
doit déjà ça et voilà maintenant elles
écoutent ce que les personnes qui ont
souhaité sa mort honte à lui dire que le
fait important de cette matinée c'est
que les deux qpc qui avaient été déposés
ont été jugées comme étant non sérieuse
par le tribunal
c'est à dire que l'un des avocats
prétendait que la loi schiappa n'était
pas conforme à la constitution et que le
tribunal a jugé que cette question
n'était même pas sérieuse et que donc le
pouf le procès pouvait reprendre sur le
fond nous en sommes évidemment
satisfaits
voilà pour la déclaration de m richard
malka ce je vous l'avais dit cette
audience elle est toujours en cours
d'autres déclarations elles sont
également à suivre puisque ce n'est pas
la fin de ce procès alors les prévenus
ils sont 13
l'avait dit ils ont entre 18 ans et 35
ans et bien il encourt deux ans
d'emprisonnement et 30 mille euros
damende pour le harcèlement en ligne et
trois ans d'emprisonnement et 45000
euros damende pour elle et menaces de
mort une autre audience est prévue
demain matin pour évoquer les faits
merci mon amour et l' or en direct du
tribunal de justice de paris